hi this is um just a general
piece of Chit Chat really
but the first day of another New Year
and obviously I've seen many of them
and like most of you uh
I've made over the years New Year's
resolutions
and um
really succeeded in many
and then a few years ago I well quite a
few years ago I realized that um
why are we in this habit of waiting for
a new year to come round to make a
resolution
and whether we succeed or not I have
succeeded in a few but normally it's
been well within the year because I've
had to
re-evaluate the
challenges several times before I was
able to to achieve them
one was giving up alcohol completely
that was about something 12 13 years ago
now and smoking was another one
a few years before that I think I gave
up
swearing
because well I was a motor mechanic
working with a
a vast amount of men in a very large
Workshop
swearing was commonplace
anyway I thought about it and realized
that as it wasn't really the person I am
and this is really what today's talk is
about is who are we
we tend to go from year to year and not
really change
we want to change it's all that Our
intention is to change but we very
rarely
do we set ourselves a task and yet
somehow we're happy in that same old
Groove in life and um
as much we want to change it's as if we
we want somebody else to help us to do
it
because it's perhaps too big a challenge
for ourselves to to do and make the
change
anyway as I say I've succeeded in a few
and as I've got older
um the challenges are seem to be harder
to do
those that know me think that I'm very
productive positive person but I
personally feel that I'm a very lazy
person when it comes to achieving a new
goal
this brings me on to
what Aikido has done
I think even though I've done yoga
Aikido Tai Chi meditation
my own form of healing that I discovered
many years ago
becoming clairvonne what was soon to be
another accident so perhaps our lives
are planned out long ago who knows
fate
occasionally I get thoughts in my head
and years later
that thought pops up
and it keeps popping up and I I think
yes
it does seem to keep repeating itself
that thought perhaps that is my destiny
I won't go into saying what they are
because they're personal to me
but uh
that certain thoughts do not change you
may have the same thoughts pop up
you may worry about your health perhaps
your family it's uh notoriously had
heart problems or stroke problems
whatever the health issues are you may
think that you've inherited them
and yet
you may not have them but you'll carry
the worry year after year
I think the biggest thing Aikido has
done for me because that was the first
one I started before I done all the
others
it opened the door and it changed me as
a person
perhaps that was the door I had to go
through
to be the person I am today
you know I think I've said before
another
videos that
I was very selfish person when I first
started and we and it was me me me
and the things that I want out of life
I remember not really wanting to touch
people you know somebody would
have stiff shoulders and I would be
happy to watch another person massage
another person's shouldered us
but not me
um
but slowly
by training hard on the mat and
suffering pain
having realizations that
I'm nobody special
I suffer like anybody else I laugh like
others
I drink and get stupid like others
wonder why I done it when will I realize
that it's futile to
keep hiding from
the mirror that you look at yourself in
and think
when will I change and you're asking
yourself this question when will I
change when will I improve
and yet you're the only person who can
change that you're the only person who
can improve that
sadly my heart is in pain at the moment
each day with the war going on
between Russia and Ukraine
because I know the Russian people so
well I know that they're good people
well the people I've met now
they only want the same as I want and
that is to be healthy have enough money
to live
and be happy for my family
I don't want to change the subject into
a doom and gloom one
but I have adult children now
and a lot of my Russians do Aikido
students I've watched them from a
teenager
to adulthood get married have children
how like me they were besotted with
their children with the albacotted with
their children
and that I watched the children grow
from a baby
to young teenagers
one of them now has a daughter in her
mid-20s
if that was a boy
perhaps they'll be called up to go to
war
through no fault of his home they might
be quite happily
living life
getting drunk
having fun with his friends
may have a good job
have enough money to do what they want
travel
have holidays do all the things that any
other person wants out of life that is
just to be happy work have enough money
to do what things that buy a house rent
a nice apartment
and yet someone can dictate to them that
they've got to go to war and possibly
die for that
past other person's cause and not their
own
to me training Aikido has taught me all
these things and it's if anything
softened my heart
softened my heart enough that I cry for
these people the Russian people
Ukrainian people
the people in other War zones around the
world
it's just going on all the time
and yet we fell here like in the UK
isolated from anything like this unless
we wish to be involved
and I know that
wherever you are in the world listening
to me
you may or not even be bothered by it
but because I used to try to travel to
Russia 3 up to three times a year
I'm very involved because I therefore be
going back again
in my lifetime perhaps I will always say
but
how life can be changed by
other people
dictators
and all we want to do is live happily
but going back to the IKEA this is what
Aikido has done for me it's opened up my
heart
it's allowed me to see
what others suffer
what others require the same as
pretty much everyone requires around the
world
so my message really today is
not of Durham and Gloom
but if you want to make a New Year's
resolution
don't wait for it each year to come
round to the first of the month first of
January or whenever your first of the
year starts
if you get an idea
don't put it off and keep saying oh next
year I'll do this or next
you know
or the New Year's over here and then I'm
going to do this
if you were sent to war you may not see
next year
so each day is a very precious day to us
if you want to what some of my people
may call waste your day and do nothing
that's your choice it's no one else's
choice
don't feel guilty about it you possibly
need the rest
but but if you decide that you're going
to do something
my advice is seek it out
is it durable
can you give it the time required
face up to the the thing that it may be
hard it may be a joy to think about
doing it but it may be harder to
actually do it
be determined see it through
a lot
and on your way of saying it through
you will meet other people you will get
to know other people
you might befriend other people you may
even fall in love with other people
it doesn't matter what it is but it's a
step into
the unknown
far more than perhaps you make this safe
think
you may decide as simple as you're going
to start walking more
you may say good morning to more people
you may just smile at more people
if a car passes you on the street and
somebody notices your eyes you may smile
at them
this is all about giving and helping
it's all part of what Aikido really is
and that is to try to make a better
world
for yourself
and those around you
thank you for listening to my message
I hope that it helps someone
in the past I have had people write to
me years later than when I met them
saying how my words help them
while other people's words have helped
me from time to time
and I wish you well in your quest and if
you don't want to make any New Year's
resolutions at any time throughout the
year that's your choice also
I hope to find some new Strength this
year and to do something to give to
others so that they may be wiser than
what I was when I was young
thank you for your time
Happy New Year